Technology has given us so many gifts
but one thing it has robbed us of
is the ability to remember phone numbers.
Apparently, Southern Living reports,
that we are in a code red situation,
no one remembers or even tries to remember
phone numbers anymore.
It's so true.
I remember, I wonder if you guys do too.
All my friends from middle school,
I still to this day could call them right now.
If you gave me like a phone, I could dial-
Really?
100%, I swear I would give 'em to you right now,
but you probably call 'em, but I do.
I would.
But my fiance's phone number,
I couldn't tell you what it is.
Shut up, you don't know Wellington's phone number?
No, I think that it starts with a three.
But his number one in my heart, you guys, he is.
Oh my God, you're the living example of this story.
Because back in the day, we used to have to call people
and dial the number.
And now you just push Wellington, you just pushed Drew,
so you don't have to memorize them.
Okay, I've been working on making sure my daughters
know the phone numbers, the addresses,
all of that kind of emergency stuff.
Because the point of this article was
what happens in an emergency?
I have no, I really have no idea what I would do.
And I love that Drew plans for emergencies.
She has a landline.
Yeah, uh-huh, in the house for emergencies, right?
Yes, but here is the thing that just peeves me to no end,
oh God, you really wanna see me work myself up to a lather?
Oh God, did I bring up the landline?
Okay, what?
You did, so it turns out now, (hisses),
landlines are connected to your cable.
And guess what the cable's attached to?
Digital.
And guess what digital is?
It is not a landline.
So if your power goes out, your phone goes out.
Do you bring this kind of stuff up on dates?
You know what bugs me is my landline, that's what bugs me.
Well, I would say if any guy would reject me for that,
then, you know, 'C'est La Vie.
'C'est La Vie, that's good point.
Well here's another relationship question.
Oh, I love this story.
You know, people are dating, people are in relationships,
and if you are dating, there's a new term called
dawn dating, D-A-W-N.
Metro reports more singles are mingling as the sun comes up,
they're opting for early morning coffee dates.
Okay, they say, here are the benefits.
It's alcohol free, that's a benefit?
I don't drink, and I even am like
bottomless brunch exists, go for it.
For a reason.
But they say, it's also, in the morning,
dawn dating, you feel bright eyed and bushy tailed going in.
And there's a time limit.
You both have to be on with your day at some point,
so you can cut it short if you're not being feeling it.
Yeah, I don't like it.
(audience laughs)
Really?
I don't, no, not at all, and maybe for you, good for you,
if it works, but no.
If somebody asked me Ross, do you wanna go out on a date?
And I was like, yeah,
and they were like, you wanna meet at IHOP?
No, no, I don't.
I would, I like to party early,
like I don't drink, but you know, I'm not sober.
And I'm going to Vegas with a bunch of girlfriends
and like, I wanna just like start partying at like 10:00 AM
and like go hit the slots, and like the black jack table,
like, we're going to like some shows
and they start at like 8:30 at night.
I'm like, I'm not gonna make it till 8:30
No, we're not gonna make it till 8:30
Like, I like to be in bed by 6:00 PM
with my food on my thing, like done.
You and I are on the same timetable.
Let me tell you.
But it's just about meeting somebody.
I'm not that interesting that early in the morning,
you know what I mean?
But some people, you know, they like a morning situation.
So if you're up for that, why not a, you know, just saying.
Well, someone's an early bird.
(upbeat music)